un tapete rectangular mide 7 pies de
largo y la medida de su diagonal es de
raíz de 74 pies determina el ancho del
tapete muy bien de este lado voy a
dibujar el tapete es un tapete
rectangular nos dicen que tiene 7 pies
de largo lo cual voy a marcar en color
verde aquí tiene 7 pies 7 pies de largo
7 pies y nos dicen que la medida de su
diagonal es de raíz de 74 pies y eso lo
voy a marcar con color azul entonces voy
a trazar la diagonal de aquí para acá y
nos dicen que la longitud de esa
diagonal es de raíz de 74 lo voy a hacer
un poco más grande de 74 pies y es muy
bien a partir de eso debemos determinar
el ancho del tapete y tal vez ya te
hayas dado cuenta que esto de acá es un
triángulo rectángulo este ángulo que
queda aquí como es un ángulo en un
rectángulo es un ángulo recto vale es un
ángulo de 90 grados y por lo tanto este
lado de acá que es el opuesto al de 90
grados este
es la hipotenusa así que podemos
utilizar el teorema de pitágoras para
encontrar la longitud que nos falta esto
de acá que sería el ancho salen déjame
ponerle un nombre le voy a poner a ok
entonces utilizando el teorema de
pitágoras sabemos que al cuadrado a al
cuadrado más 7 al cuadrado más 7 al
cuadrado es igual es igual a raíz de 74
raíz de 74 raíz de 74 elevada al
cuadrado elevada al cuadrado muy bien
vamos a desarrollar un poco nos queda
que a cuadrada +49 más 49 es igual a
raíz de 74 al cuadrado que justo es 74 a
saleh y ahora podemos restar 49 de ambos
lados menos 49 aquí menos 49 acá
y obtenemos los siguientes de este lado
se cancela en los 49 solo nos queda al
cuadrado y eso es igual a 74
49 como le podemos hacer podemos restar
50 llegamos a 25 y sumamos a 24 y
sumamos 1 entonces nos queda 25 y otra
vez restar 49 es restar 50 nos lleva 24
y sumamos 1 nos lleva a 25 bueno pues
para encontrar el valor de amd
simplemente sacamos raíz cuadrada de
ambos lados nos queda que a
a es igual es igual a 5 muy bien
entonces el ancho de este tapete es de 5
pies 5 pies